our continuing bill of the month
partnership that we have with kaiser
Health News and NPR today examines
unexpected medical cost so this morning
were focusing on the cost of the corona
virus a Denver father told us he was
built for thousands of dollars in
medical charges after an ER visit for
corona virus like symptoms I would have
coughing fits that I'd be trying to
carry my son up the stairs and I had to
sit down I couldn't make it upstairs in
early April Timothy Regan went to Denver
Health Hospital he got an
electrocardiogram and a lung x-ray but
was not given a nasal swab test in a
statement Denver Health Hospital said at
the time of mr. Egan's visit it followed
CDC recommendations and was only able to
test individuals for kovin 19 who had
severe respiratory symptoms the hospital
says mr. Eagan symptoms did not meet the
requirements for kovat 19 test regan was
presumed kovat positive by an ER doctor
in self quarantine and after a couple of
weeks he started to feel better then the
bill came we've never really seen a girl
like that so it took us completely
off-guard that bill totalled more than
$3,200 his insurer United Healthcare
covered part of his bill but that left
Regan owing more than 2,200 dollars in
out-of-pocket expenses it's like I mean
it was basically stuff in the face when
we got the bill but on March 18th
before Regan's hospital visit Congress
passed the families first coronavirus
response act that requires health
insurers to waive cost-sharing for
coronavirus testing several major
insurers are also voluntarily waiving
co-pays for coronavirus treatment
including UnitedHealthcare under most
plans it felt like UnitedHealthcare
would not live up to their end of the
deal unless we held them accountable
United Healthcare is reviewed Regan's
case at the request of kaiser Health
News
and in a statement to CBS News United
Healthcare said this weary process mr.
regan's original claims after reviewing
the services that he received all cost
share for that visit has been waived so
that's
News joining us is dr. Elizabeth
Rosenthal she's editor in chief at
kaiser Health News
good morning to you dr. Rosenthal so why
did the Regan family get billed this
much to begin with
well Congress of insurers have made all
of these promises to waive co-pays for
treatment and testing but we're hearing
that's not always the reality so what
happens is in his case no one wrote
Kovac 19 on the coding right so that
when the insurance processes in the bill
they don't see Kovac 19 code so they
think of just in New York is it now
there's plenty of blame to go around
here so you know sometimes we feel like
it's intentional sometimes and oversight
and it's often hard to know because an
insurer can in some ways rightfully push
back and say oh that was just an ER
evaluation well he didn't have köppen or
there was no Kovac tests done the hence
here goes thousands of dollars to the
consumer and that's just not right it's
a it's kind of breaking promises to me
well you know thank you to kaiser Health
News for pointing it out to saying hey
you guys sure you know don't you want to
look at this bill again and they did and
then decided okay this isn't the right
thing to do
what do you say to other families that
may find themselves in this position
well I'm saying can't call you these
bills right and you have a leg to stand
on right mine sure made a promise to me
it's largely just a kind of coding
loophole that his care was encoded as
Kovac 19 because he didn't have the test
and therefore didn't qualify for that
actual code so what I'm telling everyone
when they go to the emergency room the
first thing is to say make sure you put
Kovan 19 suspected Kovac 19 on the chart
and then you have a leg to stand on and
you should find it the other thing that
we see a lot because we're seeing all
different kinds of manipulation with
these bills is people do the right thing
as
did you call the hotline first they say
go to urgent care Urgent Care says well
we're not equipped yet to test for : 19
go to the ER and then you stuck with all
these huge ER bills which were the brunt
of his bill you know he probably didn't
need an emergency will but he had to go
there in order to get checked for kovat
and that's not right either all right
yeah it doesn't sound right but it does
sound like they've rectified it so again
thank you to kaiser Health News for
stepping in